porque vamos a hablar de la amenaza que
representa el calentamiento global con
su amplia gama de continuos impactos
sobre nuestra salud y bienestar las
inundaciones el aumento del nivel del
mar las olas de calor extremo y también
fríos extremos sin duda tienen efecto en
nuestra salud y en el ecosistema el
mundo necesita con urgencia una
estrategia global para minimizar estas
enfermedades y muertes relacionadas con
esta crisis climática que vamos a ver
más común en los próximos años en las
próximas décadas saludamos a xavier de
lo él es médico cirujano y analista en
políticas de salud y autor del libro la
tragedia del desabasto xavier gracias
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 también está con
nosotros en el estudio más romeros a la
buenos días también muchas gracias por
acompañarnos queríamos empleos pero
queremos empezar haciendo una revisión
en general de la situación que nuevas
dinámicas en la epidemiología en las
enfermedades pueden darse con el
caliente con el calentamiento global
sí yo creo que primero que nada las más
obvias no que es precisamente el cambio
que hay de hábitos entre las poblaciones
porque porque comenzamos a vestirnos de
manera distinta a agruparnos de manera
distinta y no es lo mismo cuando en
determinado momento nosotros tenemos
teníamos por ejemplo un invierno que
fuera bastante tranquilo ahora que
tenemos como se llama estaciones muy
extremas en las cuales la gente tiene
que estar completamente guardada y esto
hace que se contagien de otro tipo de
enfermedades 2 primero los cambios en la
en la actividad humana veranos muy
cálidos que hacen que se consuman
alimentos de otra manera y que éstos
pudieran llegar a echarse a perder o
causar alguna enfermedad digamos que es
lo más básico realmente lo preocupante
es cuando comenzamos a ver nosotros
migraciones de otro tipo de enfermedades
como las causadas por vectores
curiosamente en américa latina donde
tenemos endemia de enfermedades
transmitidas por picaduras de mosquitos
por este tipo de vectores con que ya se
empieza como en algunos casos el
mosquito aedes egypti que es el
responsable de enfermedades como dengue
sica y chikungunya número 1 ha comenzado
a migrar a asia hacia las latitudes que
antes se consideraban más frías y por
otro lado comienza a subir de altitud
entonces en algunas ciudades de
altitudes como ciudad de méxico
posiblemente las partes altas de
colombia que todavía no
era endémica había casos aislados de
estas enfermedades ya comenzamos a
verlas de otra manera no y por ultimo
evidentemente que estemos nosotros
desbalanceando completamente en los
ecosistemas y comiencen a manifestarse
nuevos tipos de bacterias o nuevos tipos
de virus
y esto nos va a dar un problema también
esa vía requería preguntar sobre todo
por eso estas olas de calor extremo que
estamos viviendo pues en europa también
en américa del norte y por supuesto en
sur américa en nuestra región de américa
latina y el caribe que otras
enfermedades podemos ver además como la
más común que pues es este qué causa el
dengue el chikungunya el cica también y
le quería preguntar lo estamos
conversando con más romero que otras
enfermedades también del hemisferio
norte se pudieran trasladar a américa
latina
bueno la realidad es que normalmente lo
que hemos visto es este momento son
cambios en las enfermedades de tipo
infecciosa pero lo que sí puede y la
mayor parte de ellas son causadas por
vectores sin embargo hay un punto en
todas estas ciudades que antes no tenían
estas olas de calor tan amplias estamos
viendo también problemas de
deshidrataciones y problemas de
suministro de agua y esto puede llegar a
casa a ocasionar epidemias sanitarias
tipo salmonelosis o tipo cólera y hay
que recordar que entre más tiempo existe
en este tipo de epidemias en algunas
regiones más variabilidad pueden tener
los organismos entonces de repente
podríamos nosotros llegar a tener una
infección por el vibrio cholera que
produce esta infección y que comenzará a
tener algunas variantes o mutaciones
resistentes a antibióticos esto va a ser
un problema se ha empezado a ver también
que algunas super infecciones sobre todo
las causadas por estafilococo que son
muy resistentes a algunos tipos de
antibióticos y que se dan en la piel
comienzan a surgir en cuanto tenemos
nosotros una variación importante dentro
de la estabilidad que solía haber y las
temperaturas
doctor quería preguntarle además de
frenar el cambio climático la
deforestación en términos generales que
deberíamos estar haciendo ya en este
momento para prepararnos de todos estos
cambios epidemiológicos que nos pueden
esperar en el futuro tanto en el norte
como en el sur global
es una excelente pregunta porque creo
que si algo hemos aprendido curiosamente
con esos cambios y además a partir de la
pandemia es retomar algunas enseñanzas
sanitarias que aparentemente se nos
habían olvidado no como el lavado de
manos el tener los cuidados básicos
sanitarios por ejemplo hervir el agua
está este auge enorme de agua
embotellada que tenemos nos ha hecho
olvidar que en algunas ocasiones estamos
contaminando los suministros de agua
tenemos los casos más comunes no cuando
nosotros queremos tomar agua embotellada
pero estamos tomando hielos fabricados
con el agua local que nunca pasó por un
filtro pues no debemos confiarnos
tenemos que reeducar una vez más a los
niños para el lavado de manos y tenemos
que presionar mucho a las autoridades
para que siempre mantengan los servicios
básicos sanitarios como es el control de
excretas y cómo es el drenaje xavier
también le queríamos preguntar sobre la
deforestación nosotros estamos
evidentemente invadiendo el hábitat
natural cada vez más de los animales
vimos también lo que pasó con que
posiblemente pudo saltar de un animal a
nosotros posiblemente no pues pasó a un
animal a nosotros también lo estamos
viendo ahora con esta emergencia
sanitaria también global de la viruela
del mono podemos seguir viendo más
amenazas digamos más enfermedades que
salten de animales hacia nosotros
humanos
es probable pero creo que es responsable
que yo haga una acotación nosotros
siempre habíamos visto cómo pasan las
enfermedades desde las obvias es decir
detrás vamos a llamarles epidemias en
los animales hacia los seres humanos el
problema que tenemos hoy no es tanto
por una invasión del hábitat que si
hemos invadido el hábitat y seguramente
que estamos mucho más cerca de estos
animales pero la realidad de las cosas
es que también tenemos una mayor
velocidad de la comunicación que lo que
quiero decir con esto es que si estas
epidemias se hubieran visto hace cien
años seguramente hubieran sido mortales
y devastadoras para ciertos centros
poblacionales pero el hecho de que
alguien hoy se pueda comunicar de una
zona que se encuentra infectada en menos
de cuatro horas puede estar a miles de
kilómetros contagiando a más personas
ayuda bastante si la realidad es que
tiene y cuidar el medio ambiente y
tenemos que proteger muchísimo a las
especies y que no ayuda para nada que el
ser humano esté cada vez más cerca
conviviendo con especies que
potencialmente pueden estar infectadas